Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. It really is a grey old day here, the rain pouring relentlessly down, and what I wouldn't give for a little bit of the Aegean sunshine. Well, as it happens, Tom Holland always brings a little bit of Greece with him, don't you, Tom? Thank you so much, Tommy. That's a charming thing to say. And in fact, you have very kindly already allowed
me to do one episode on ancient greece we covered the trojan war um and because i'm a glutton for good things i would like to uh return to that um and today we are going to look perhaps more broadly not just the trojan war but at the whole field of greek mythology but it's going to be a different kind of podcast because um for the first time we have a guest. And I think that, you know, when we have our first guest on this podcast, it's got to be a special guest. Definitely. Well, Dominic, for our first guest, I've chosen a polymath, a comedian, an actor, a novelist, an all-round Renaissance man. And it's the definition of a Renaissance man, I think, that he should love ancient Greece and perhaps specifically its mythology. So the Renaissance man that I have invited on is Mr Stephen Fry, who is joining us from California,
has a new book out on the Trojan War. Stephen, thanks so much for joining us. It's a pleasure. And as a Renaissance man, in your honour, I'm even wearing tights. Which we can't see on the set, but I'm sure it looks absolutely gorgeous under the desk. So Stephen, we've already had one episode on the Trojan War war so it is a treat to get back to it um and you you've got um new book about it and it's the third in a sequence of books that you've written about greek myths how much were you looking forward to getting to the trojan war enormously i mean both as uh in a positive way and also the slight sense of dread, because I knew that at least the Trojan War and its aftermath, or after myth, ho-ho, would lead to an end of the story of Greek myth.
One can overdo how shaped Greek myth is and how much of a literary performance, rather than a folk performance it might be. But more than most mythic cycles, it seems to begin at the beginning with the birth of the gods and end with the coming home of characters like Odysseus, the nostos, as the Greeks call it, that wonderful sense of home, which can so easily symbolically seem like mankind coming home to itself and no longer needing gods to explain the oddities of
the world or to interfere and intervene in the way that gods used to do and used to do in almost all cultures and you know british folk had fairies and little people who used to dwell amongst us supposedly and and almost all myths have have this idea that there was a time when gods and men trod the earth together and uh the fact that it had to come to an end somehow that the trojan war um and particularly the coming home even the tragic coming home of agamemnon and um and uh and the slightly less happy coming home of uh helen and menelaus and the slightly less happy coming home of Helen and Menelaus, and the apparently happy coming home of Odysseus to the hearth, to their own families, to their own problems and squabbles, rather than just continuing to be puppets of the gods,
is a wonderful sense of closure anyway. But the Trojan War is the final explosion of gods and humanity broiling together under the sun in the dust and um that's something i've i've really looked forward to i tell you the thing i didn't look forward to because i don't think of myself as that sort of person was the butch mano a mano fighting that uh formed so much of the iliadad. And I thought I would get rather, but, you know, reading it again, it is extraordinary how beautiful, poetic, strong and perfect, really,
Homer's writing about these fights is. You would think they become repetitive and boring, even in the violence of, you know, blood and brains shooting out of the sockets of a helmet and some of the really quite cinematic and horrific images, you would think you'd tire of them. But actually there's something quite genuinely noble and remarkable about the fighting which I never thought I would find because I think of myself as a typical child of my age
for whom militarism and the warrior code is for saps and is for Spartans and we're all Athenians, you know. That sort of sense that it's a bit over, it's part of what we now call toxic masculinity. And yet characters like Ajax and Hector and Achilles and Diomedes, you know, the real warriors in the story, as opposed to the sharp operators like Odysseus and Nestor and so on. There is a quality to them that continues to speak to you across the thousands of years um that that is just remarkable and i was very pleased that my publishers when they read the manuscript they found that that the actual fighting in the sand in front of the walls of troy was for them really important part of it if i can um i know tom wants
to ask you lots of questions about myth in general but one thing that interests me so your first book in this cycle was about the gods and then you sort of did heroes. And this one you've moved a tiny bit more towards history because the Trojan War is an event that people argue about. So was that, did you write about it in exactly, were you conscious of adopting the same voice as it were that you had with the earlier books?
It's a really good point that, Dominic. And yes, it's part of what I was saying about coming to the end of the mythic nature of this whole story as it becomes to leak into historicity of some kind. I think it's fair to say that for most of the modern age, what we call the modern age, we didn't think of the Trojan War
as having any historical basis. And it wasn't really until Schliemann and the late 19th century and his excavations that this idea that it could really have happened, that there could have been a war in a historical place like that, became clearer and clearer. Though, of course, that's a whole other story. Schliemann was a showman and a fraud and all kinds of things. And as some archaeologists made the point that with his
dynamite and his readjusting of the sites, he finally destroyed Troy in a way that the Greek armies never could. But yes, it is interesting. And I had an image for it, which is rather cute, I suppose, and therefore not necessarily to be trusted. But it works as an analogy to some extent, that when you begin at the very beginning of the myths, you have these almost archetypal figures, these primordial deities who are what they represent. So Ouranos, whom we amusingly call Uranus, of course, is the sky. And to this day, the Greek word for sky is Ouranos.
So in that sense, you're talking about personifications of abstract or meteorological ideas and elements in the world and the cosmos that humans apprehend. And they give them a name and an agency. And that's a very basic God. And I remember thinking, this is a bit like the early days of computer gaming, when in the first generation of four-bit computing, it was very blocky. And there was no resolution, there were no curves. The colours were very basic, just the primary colours of light, you know, red, green, blue and yellow. And then 8-bit and 16-bit, you started to get anti-aliasing,
as they call it in the graphics world, and you got these polygons with more shapes and more resolution because there was more power and more computing. So by the time you got to the turn of the century, each new generation of computer graphics was becoming more resolved, richer, more complex, more real. And it's the same with the personalities of Greek myth. It starts with these, the sky, the earth, darkness, you know light these are the gods ether you know and so on and then the race of titans is born from that and they have a little more personality you can see chronos and the others and rhea they've got they've definitely got personality they're 8-bit or 16-bit even and but then their children zeus and here and poseidon and Demeter and so on, they really have character and personality and richness.
And then the next generations, including, of course, humankind that are made by Prometheus. And so you start to get this, as I say, a bit like computer gaming. You start to get a landscape of entities, of divine beings that have real ambiguity and complexity and contradiction. They are, as Ian Forster would say, rounded characters rather than flat characters. They have resolution, you know. They're 4K HDR. And they've got all the... And that becomes even truer as you move into the Trojan arena where you can see it is all about the flaws in humanity and in the gods that drive the story
rather than just plain clunky lust or ambition, but conflicting motives that give rise to questions that people still ask today. So, of course, I'm talking as if assuming that everybody knows the story of the Trojan War, but perhaps people will know enough at least to know that the proschema, as historians like to say, the casus belli, the cause of the whole thing, the bone of contention or the apple of discord, in fact, is all about Helen of Sparta, who is abducted. And there I've used the word and taken to Troy and becomes Helen of Troy. And of course, she is, as I say, the bone of contention.
But the question you're bound to ask when reading Homer, who back references, obviously, to that story of Paris coming to Sparta to take her, and we still don't know, reading the whole of the Iliad and reading the sources after, the Smyrnaeus, Quintus Smyrnaeus and others, you still don't know, does Helen come willingly? Is she hypnotised by Aphrodite, the dullest answer perhaps?
Or is it as you sense that she was glamorised by this very handsome Trojan prince, but that slowly his vanity, his surface qualities, his lack of bravery or self-knowledge or honor caused the love to die? eye. And that is much more interesting. And it's sketched in so lightly by Homer that you can't quite believe you've read that much into it. But that's part of Homer's genius, I think. Yeah, well, I was going to say on the topic of Helen, I mean, part of the fascination of all the figures of Greek myth is that when you write about them, say, in a book like yours, they are unitary characters, and they are the compound of all the mystery and all the many different things that have been written about them by different people. So Helen, of course, you know, she's not just the subject of Homer. Many different writers wrote about her and many
different writers attributed different motives to her. And I wonder when you are writing about the gods or the heroes or Helen, you are having to draw on multiple sources. How easy did you find it to blend those sources so that you had kind of a sense of unitry characters when you were writing about them? That's a really good question. And of course, it's impossible not somehow to take sides, if that's the right phrase. Most people of my generation and background who, you know, studied classics a bit at school, you know, up to A-level at least, and certainly not academically qualified to pronounce too much on it, but most of us tend naturally to side with the Greeks in the Trojan War, the Achaeans, whatever you want to call the side that's come to collect Helen, just because that's the civilization that we regard as the one that's
primary. But whenever you get involved with the story, you can't help feeling extreme admiration and respect for Priam and his family with the exception of Paris and Diphobus perhaps but generally speaking Hector and Andromache are so lovable and splendid and Odysseus is genuinely so twisted and cruel and Agamemnon is so pompous and absurd and lacks self-knowledge to such a great degree and you start to get furious with the Greeks and you realize that nonetheless you are telling the story from their point of view and I think the way I got inside the characters and tried to have my own well tried to let them speak for themselves but under my own, well, tried to let them speak for themselves, but under my own guidance, obviously, was by mostly having Odysseus as the point of consciousness for me, even if I don't tell the story entirely from his point of view. It is usually Odysseus watching Agamemnon or seeing
something dishonorable happen and being a little bit cynical about it. And, you know, that sort of allows one to have the ironic distance, because I think Odysseus has an ironic distance from a lot of this. And he never wanted to be there, and he very rarely reveals what he thinks um but but he he allows one to see the dark side and the good side of every character i i mean it's not a wholly literary or satisfactory way of doing it but of course you can't just fill it with footnotes i'm not a historian i can't say but for some people helen was the shrew of all ages. For others, she was a cult who was worshipped here, there, and so on.
Because almost every character takes on huge meaning to subsequent generations. So Diomedes had temples to him and so on. But you can't stop and do all of that. I think you have to allow the reader to be surprised by how upset they are, perhaps, at the fall of Troy. Because we've all wanted it you think come on we've got to we've got to win the Greeks have got somehow to win and when the Trojan Horse finally works it is one is disgusted I think by the violence by the horror by Neoptolemus Achilles son his particular horrific cruelty and violence.
And it's never held back by the writers. Obviously, Homer isn't there in terms of the story of the Iliad. It's finished long ago. It ends with the funeral of Hector. But he refers to what will happen and then other sources like Virgil and Quintus Menaeus give good descriptions of terrible violence and we feel responsible I think that's part of the in the same way I suppose that an intelligent and sensitive student reading about the massacre at Amritsar would feel somehow complicit just by being British. It's nonsense. We weren't there. It wasn't our decision.
We're not General Dyer. We're not, you know, we're not responsible for it. And yet it's a stain on something to do with our identity. We won't go too far into the horrors of identitarian politics just now. But you know what i mean that there is a it's part of the literary adventure of history is that you cannot but identify and in identifying when the side that you allow yourself to does something dreadful you feel that you've done that dreadful thing but stephen doesn't this raise an interesting question, which is that writing about this, I mean, this was a story that was told in a culture that was much more violent than our own, with a cult of honour that we barely understand. And it must be an interesting challenge to retell that story for basically, you know, there's always that argument, which I imagine we all find quite irritating about relevance, about the relevance of myths and history and whatnot. But it must be a challenge to write about this story for an audience that don't prize those
things, for whom violence is repellent. Yeah, you're absolutely right. I think it's one of the real difficulties facing historians and retellers of any tale of the past. And I'm talking about the recent past, which you, Dominic, know very well, well for example have made your study is that subsequent generations find it very hard sometimes to understand what you might call the codes behind yeah so for example and i my generation of god sons and nephews and nieces it's sometimes if i watch a film like i don't know it could it could be Brief Encounter or The Way to the Stars, some Second World War movie, they genuinely say to me, did people talk like that? And I'll think, actually, is it that odd?
I say, well, maybe it is. So why don't they, why do they hide everything? They don't talk about what they're feeling at all. And I think, gosh, that is true. I mean, we sort of knew as a kind of joke about those stiff upper-lipped Englishmen, but come to think of it, Michael Redgrave and Kenneth Moore, Johnny Mills or whoever,
they speak off the subject all the time. And this is recent. You know, I knew Johnny Mills. He was actually a very close friend. And my parents' generation were exactly that generation. And I don't think of them as being a different sort of human. And yet the codes of conduct and of emotional language and even of what is loss, what is honour,
what it is to be a good human, there are a lot of very puritanical young people looking back at recent culture and judging it. And as you know, we now have to have apologies up in front of every film to explain that they reflect a different way of looking at the world so if you go back thousands of years to the bronze age where that you're not you haven't even got the advantage of a of writing to give you an insight all you have is the marvelous detail of for example a good example of what i guess you're referring to dominic would be the the the code of of what to do with the dead body
which is to us a kind of well we might know the story of antigony which all revolves around not you know not burying someone so and we know that it's important in the Middle East to cover a body very early. So you can sort of get the idea that... But we tend to use what I think anthropology has called the functional fallacy. That's to say, we say, oh, yes, you cover a body early because otherwise it corrupts. There must be a good scientific quick reason.
That's the reason behind kosher food. It spoils in the heat. Everything has to have a reason. Whereas's the reason behind kosher food it spoils in the heat you know everything has to have a reason whereas in the in the hermetic code the covering of a body with earth or the burning of it or the the the the expiation and the treatment of you know guest friendship and other codes like that um while you can try and put a reasoning behind it and give it a function, it's probably, without going too left-bank intellectual, it is probably better to treat it in a slightly more Levi-Strauss kind of way. It's a phenomenon of, it's an expression of behaviour
that is rewarded by examining it and thinking about it and not just instantly saying, oh, it's because. Because is actually less interesting than how, how they live this code. And as you say, the violence to us is unspeakable, partly because of the pain. We just think of the awful pain of these wounds suppurating and the screaming of men as they're hurt. And also because, you know, we don't... There's no sympathy.
It seems that all the sympathy is displaced into religious, you know, obsequies and, you know, funeral rites and ointments and unguents and so on. But that really you're looking as a Westerner with our culture and our post-romantic codes of sympathy and so on. We're looking for those tiny moments in Homer which we pick out. I choose Homer because it's the clearest source. So that would be what's he called, Antilochus, the son of Nestor, running along the sand to tell Achilles that the noise that has caused Achilles to look towards
the fighting is the fighting over the death of Patroclus. And then he has to squat in front of Achilles and hold both his hands. And as Homer says, not so much in friendship, but more to stop Achilles harming himself. And Achilles sobs and sobs. And you think there, there's a point of contact for me, a soft liberal, in the widest sense of the word, westerner with my values that come from keats and tennyson and dickens and you know the whole armory of hollywood and soft culture and
you know that we must be lovely to each other and that we when we do love each other we break down in tears and that our emotions you know have a a righteous, you know, order of expression. And so you see that finally happening in Homer, and it's like you gush with, oh, what a moment that is. Or the moment when, you know, Andromache and Hector are, you know, he's got his helmet on, and the flash of the helmet flashes in his baby, Astarnax's eyes, and Ayanax opens his eyes and starts to cry because because he's scared by the nodding plume of his father's helmet and hector laughs and takes the helmet off and they laugh at the boy for being frightened
and and underneath it all is uh andromache's thinking you're going to die today hector and he's saying i'm not going to die today it's all right not today and the you're going to die today, Hector. And he's saying, I'm not going to die today. It's all right, not today. And the child is going to die as well. And how that child dies is so horrific as well, yeah. So it's like these tiny moments. It's all you need. And it's a very important part of storytelling
is how small those moments need to be. I remember being taught this as a wonderful lesson by a friend of mine who was really my sort of rabbi for storytelling, as it were, because he spoke in a wonderfully rabbinical way. It was a man called William Goldman, Bill Goldman, who wrote Butch Cassidy, the screenplay, and The Marathon Man.
He did The Princess Bride, is that right? Princess Bride as well, yeah. Who we've already name-checked on this podcast. Never fight a land war in Asia. In Asia, it's a great one, isn't it? One of the ineluctable truths, exactly. But he was saying to me how, for example, Butch Cassidy in The Sundance Kid, he wrote as a comedy.
He said, you just need one or two tiny moments to remind the audience that what's behind this is death. And then they'll go along with the ride, they'll love the characters, but behind it all, there'll be a bell tolling. And in Butch Cassidy, it's a lot of comedy between Paul Newman and Robert Redford. But there's one moment when they get their pardon from the sheriff
and he just hands them the pardon and he looks Paul Newman in the eye and says, you're going to die bloody butch you do know that and and then there's a second of cloud goes across those blue eyes of paul newman and then he jokes again and and then katherine ross later on in the film says um says them uh when they say they're going to go to south america she says i'll cook for you i'll sew for you i'll i'll i'll do anything for you but one thing I won't do, I won't watch you die. And Bell said those are the only two moments in the film which are in any way a kind of downbeat moment,
and yet they hang over it. So for all the banter and the fun that the characters have, who are those guys? You know, all this wonderful comedy, there is that little plangent sense. and similarly in all the horror and martial conquest and genealogical genealogical name calling of families and dynasties and so on that homer gives you there are these little pinpricks of human interaction that just make the whole thing so real that you come back to it again and again. I'm Marina Hyde.
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
I remember watching Robin Lane Fox, the very distinguished classicist reciting the heart-rending end of the Iliad when Priam, the father of Hector, comes to the Greek camp to beg for the return of the body of his son, who Achilles is desecrating the body, refusing to allow it to be burned. And Priam kneels before Achilles and kisses the hands of the man who slew his son and weeps. And as Robin Lane Fox was reciting this, he began to weep. And it was an incredibly powerful moment, the kind of sense of people being joined across the millennia in this shared experience of the trauma of it.
But I was thinking, I mean, Robin Lane Fox was from a generation who marinated in the classics, absolutely kind of raised in this kind of stuff. And you were talking about that, that there's a kind of generations that were absolutely habituated to the study of Greece and of Rome. And now, as he was saying, we live in an age where that is much less the case. And yet the success of your book suggests that still, this stuff has a cut through, but perhaps particularly to children. And it's, I mean, it's odd, isn't it, that this should be so violent. It's about death, it's about slaughter, it's about rape, it's about all the most horrendous things. And yet, it always
cuts through to children. And this is how children get introduced to antiquity more times than not, certainly how I was. And isn't that a paradox? It is. And I wonder about it a lot because most of the communications I get and requests for letters and thoughts about these books is from either children or their parents. And so I have considered why it is. And I wonder if it isn't something to do with where the stories are poised between reality and symbolism.
I mean, I'm sure you get this, both of you, and yet it's quite hard to explain why I think these stories are so different from fantasy. Because people will say, oh, yes, because I love the Game of Thrones or I love Tolkien or something. And I'll go, yes, well, very nice too. And they'll say, but that's similar, isn't it?
It's got dragons and monsters and people with superpowers. And I go, yes. And yet, while that's true, I don't think of Greek mythology as being like that, even though it reasonably is. And nobody likes people to be snobbish about fantasy franchises. And, you know, it doesn't help with the study of classics or the study of
history to be dismissive of passions that young people have in terms of storytelling so if they love their tolkien and their jk rowling and their game of thrones and their marvel cinematic universe then that's that's fine but i think the the god's thing thing is somehow children are aware of this sense of belonging in a special space where humans and these fictional gods, they don't really believe in, but they know they're on their side. The children know about them. They've collected their details. They feel they can belong in that world. And I think they love what academics call double determination, which sounds a very strange idea, but is one of the things that's particularly interesting in late Greek myth is when, say, Paris is aiming his arrow at Achilles, you can tell the story that he gets off a lucky shot
and it lands in the heel of Achilles. Or you can say that Apollo appeared and held the arrow for him, held the bow and guided the shot because that's what Apollo, god of archery, might do. And he's on the side of the Trojans. And it is actually written that he would be, in some respects, the author of Achilles' death. There's an earlier prophecy about that. Well, so you could say, as Homer does, that there is apollo and there is paris or you can be more like an author is saying oh the muse wasn't with me with me last night the author doesn't really think
there's a muse whispering in their ear but if the muse is with them they'll go oh the muse was absolutely in my ear and i wrote and i wrote and it was amazing. And wow. And then she went, you know, and it's, you know, cricketers will say the same about mother cricket or, you know, or form, you know, is a kind of God that settles on you. And every Greek archer in thousands of years after the Greek war would have said, come on, Apollo, guide my arrow, because that's just like Basil Forty saying, thank you, God. You know, it's just a thing we do. So you can read the whole of the Iliad and the whole of the Odyssey and decide that the gods are symbolic purely and that it doesn't really, when Athena tells Achilles to calm down
and not lose his temper publicly or him, you know, and just to leave the tent, is that simply the better angels of his nature? and not lose his temper publicly or him, you know, and just to leave the tent? Is that simply the better angels of his nature? Is it the wisdom in him saying, come on, Achilles, don't lose your temper? You know, the Athena in us is that character that is wise and temperate. Do you see what I mean?
So there is this, it's double determination. You can say it's the God and have it as a fantasy world of gods actually in the battle or you can have it as these they stand for these elements that they represent i wonder if it's kind of the difference between dinosaurs and dragons that both are kind of big and fierce but dinosaurs actually existed and in the in the imagination of of the ancients the gods existed um yes and and that kind of in a way makes them because i i'm at the moment i'm kind of doing a sequel to troy so i'm writing a history of of ancient greece in which the gods do continue to play because oh they did they did have roles you know yeah philippides running from from athens to
所以这里有双重决定性。你可以说它是神，把它们当作真正参与战斗的神的奇幻世界，或者你可以把它们看作它们所代表的那些元素的化身。我在想这是否有点像恐龙和龙的区别，两者都有点庞大而凶猛，但恐龙确实存在过，而在古人的想象中，神明是存在的。是的，从某种程度上讲，这使得它们……因为我目前正在写《特洛伊》的续集，所以我正在写一部关于古希腊的历史，其中神明确实继续发挥着作用，因为哦，它们确实发挥了作用，你知道的，比如斐庇得斯从雅典跑向
summon the spartans to come and join them at Marathon. And he's running back and the Spartans have said that they're going to come late. And he meets with Pan, the great god Pan. This is what Herodotus says. And Pan says, I will be there at Marathon. And then at Marathon, sure enough, the Persians experience panic. Pan is there. And so I'm kind of writing it and putting the gods back in.
召唤斯巴达人去马拉松与他们会合。他跑回来时，斯巴达人说他们会迟到。然后他遇到了潘，伟大的神潘。希罗多德就是这么说的。潘说，我会在马拉松出现。果不其然，在马拉松战场上，波斯人感到了惊恐。潘就在那里。所以我现在正把神明重新写进历史里。
And it's kind of like rewilding history, because suddenly all kinds of things make sense. So I've been kind of thinking about this, that I think part of the appeal of it almost is entering a world in which these gods are possible, and there's something about their glamour, their mystique, the kind of way in which they behave terribly makes me it's appealing to children.
这有点像是对历史的“野化”，因为突然之间，各种事情都说得通了。所以我一直在思考这个问题，我认为这种魅力的一部分几乎是进入一个这些神明可能存在的世界，而且它们的迷人之处、神秘感、以及它们那种糟糕的行为方式，对孩子们来说很有吸引力。
I don't know. Yes. Something of that. I think you may be right, and I like your dinosaur dragons idea. I think there is this sense that I had, and I'm sure you had, as a child when reading Greek mythology, that somehow there was a... It goes back to something truthful or something pure and right,
我不知道。是的。确实有这方面的因素。我想你是对的，我很喜欢你关于恐龙与龙的想法。我觉得我有这种感觉，我相信你小时候读希腊神话时也有这种感觉，那就是某种程度上存在着一种……这可以追溯到某种真实的东西，或是某种纯粹而正确的东西，
whereas a single authored fantasy world, like Tolkien's or Narnia or any other, while it can be terrific fun, doesn't have that sort of authenticity, that sense of it belonging to something real. There's a weight, isn't there, Stephen? Yeah. I think it's kind of a weightiness that these... There's a sense of it belonging to something real there's a weight isn't there steven yeah it's kind of a weightiness that these there's a sense of rootedness i guess yes but actually i wanted to press you on this i'm glad i'm so glad you brought it up because in our house
而托尔金或纳尼亚传奇或其他任何单一作者构筑的奇幻世界，虽然可以非常有趣，但却没有那种真实感、那种属于某种真实事物的归属感。那种厚重感，对吧，斯蒂芬？是的。我觉得这是一种厚重感，这些……有一种属于真实事物的归属感，有一种厚重感，对吧，斯蒂芬？是的，这是一种厚重感，这些……有一种根基感，我想是的。是的，不过其实我想就这一点追问你一下，我很高兴你提起这个，因为在我们家里
i have a nine-year-old so you're a constant presence i mean you're you're in our ears all the time through harry potter through the hobbit the sherlock holmes audio books which you did and i'm wondering whether um i mean some of those things have a kind of mythic quality so sherlock holmes for example i mean he's become a kind of mythic character he's accumulated like a sort of old boat he's got all these kind of carbuncles on all these sort of you know he's he's more than purely the creation of arthur connor isn't? And do you think there are other modern equivalents that have become mythic in the same way as Homer's characters? I think Holmes is a pretty special example. I was thinking about this not long ago, about how many characters could you express in a game of Pictionary quite so quickly as Sherlock Holmes?
我有一个九岁的孩子，所以你是个常客。我的意思是，你一直在我们的耳边，通过《哈利·波特》、通过《霍比特人》、通过你录制的《福尔摩斯》有声书。我在想，有些东西具有某种神话般的特质——比如福尔摩斯，我的意思是，他已经变成了一种神话般的人物，他积累了像一艘旧船一样的东西，身上长满了各种各样的藤壶，你知道的，他不仅仅是亚瑟·柯南·道尔纯粹的创造，对吧？你认为还有其他现代同类角色，能够以荷马笔下人物那种方式成为神话吗？我认为福尔摩斯是一个相当特殊的例子。不久前我还一直在想，有多少角色能在“看图猜词”游戏（Pictionary）中像福尔摩斯那样被如此迅速地表现出来？
You'd have a looking glass and a deerstalker and a pipe, and instantly, wherever you were in the world, they could say, Sherlock Holmes. And, you know, you could do it, I suppose, with Charlie Chaplin as a film image character, and maybe with the circles for the ears of mickey mouse when you're moving towards the logo side of characters there but there is there is no question that sherlock holmes has extraordinary uh reach through cultures all over the world and um one can look for answers as to
你会画一面镜子、一顶猎鹿帽和一个烟斗，然后瞬间，无论你在世界的哪个角落，人们都会说：“歇洛克·福尔摩斯。”你知道的，我想查理·卓别林作为电影形象角色也可以做到这一点，或许还有当你开始接近那些角色的标志设计时，米老鼠耳朵的圆圈也是如此。但毫无疑问，歇洛克·福尔摩斯在全球各种文化中都有着非凡的影响力，而且人们可以寻找答案，探究
where that might be i suppose the most obvious one is that we all want sherlock holmes in the same way i suppose we want to jeeves you know there is this idea of wouldn't it be wonderful to have a friend, a mentor, a wise teacher who saw things and knew things and could advise us and yet, you know, be a friend and not be an emperor or in some way a terrible boss, you know, but just someone there who could just solve everything for us. And it's interesting because there isn't that much of an archetype. I mean, you could argue that Jeeves and so on is an archetype, you know, the servant that's wiser than his master goes back through Valpone and Ben Johnson
这种影响力源自何处。我想最显而易见的答案是，我们所有人都渴望拥有歇洛克·福尔摩斯，就像我们渴望拥有吉夫斯一样。你知道，会有这样一种想法：拥有一个朋友、一个导师、一个智者，他能看清事物、了解事物并给我们建议，同时还能成为我们的朋友，而不是什么高高在上的皇帝或可怕的老板，你知道的，就只是一个能为我们解决一切问题的人，这难道不是很棒吗？这很有趣，因为这种原型并不多。我的意思是，你可以说吉夫斯之流就是一个原型，你知道的，比他的主人更聪明的仆人这一形象可以追溯到沃尔彭（Volpone）和本·琼森（Ben Jonson）
and Goldoni and right back to Terence and Roscius and those Roman plays all full of stupid masters aren't they? Who are kind of equivalents of a Bertie Worcester. But to have a
以及哥尔多尼（Goldoni），一直追溯到泰伦斯（Terence）和罗休斯（Roscius），那些罗马戏剧里全都是愚蠢的主人，不是吗？他们某种程度上就相当于伯蒂·伍斯特（Bertie Wooster）。但要拥有一个
Sherlock Holmes figure, I suppose the is odysseus in a way because one of the things you can say about the trojan war again without being too sort of prescriptive about it is that um it's mankind playing out what mankind is, you know, this first test of this greatest war that's ever been, these two civilisations clashing and more soldiers and more ships and more resources being put into this fight. And what's going to win it? There's Ajax and Diomedes and all these remarkable, Hector, these great fighters, Penthesileur and Memnon
歇洛克·福尔摩斯式的人物，我想……从某种意义上说就是奥德修斯。因为关于特洛伊战争，如果不做过多清规戒律式的限定的话，你可以说的一点是，那是人类在演绎人类的本质。你知道，这是最伟大的战争的第一场考验，两大文明碰撞，更多的士兵、更多的船只、更多的资源投入到这场战斗中。什么能赢得胜利？这里有埃阿斯、狄奥米德斯以及所有这些杰出的战士——赫克托耳、彭忒西勒亚、门农
and all these amazing warriors, but they don't win it. What wins it is deceit, cunning, trickery. Those are the human qualities. And it is, you know, I mean, Nietzsche wanted us to look at Dionysus and Apollo as the two principles that are behind the Greek spirit and so on in terms of, you know, harmony, golden order, reason, numbers, prophecy, all the beauties of the Apollonian way. And then underneath that, of course, the frenzy, the appetite, the addiction, the instinct and impulse of the Dionysian way of being. But also there is in between Hermes and his descendant Odysseus, where sheer trickery, lying, deceit, storytelling, which is, of course, another aspect of Hermes,
和所有这些了不起的战士，但他们并没有赢得胜利。赢得胜利的是诡计、狡猾、欺诈。这些才是人类的品质。而且，你知道的（尼采希望我们把狄奥尼索斯和阿波罗视为希腊精神背后的两种原则，等等，就和谐、黄金秩序、理性、数字、预言以及阿波罗式道路的所有美感而言。而在那之下，当然还有狄奥尼索斯式生存方式的狂热、欲望、沉迷、本能和冲动）。但同时，在赫尔墨斯和他的后代奥德修斯之间，纯粹的诡计、谎言、欺骗、讲故事——当然这也是赫尔墨斯的一个方面，
one of his responsibilities. He's the god of storytellers as well as of liars. And storytellers are liars, of course. So maybe behind that glory, of storytellers as well as of liars and real storytellers are liars of course so maybe but behind that glory is an impish truth about humanity the um uh the Icelandic uh and Norse uh uh saga makers we're kind of familiar with but I was reading ages ago, and I can't remember who, so I may have got it very wrong. But I was reading that, as it were, on the hillside at the end of the battle, there would be two bonfires, and around one would be a group of people listening to the saga maker,
他是讲故事之神，也是骗子之神。而讲故事的人当然就是骗子。所以也许在那荣耀的背后……讲故事的人当然也是骗子，而真正的讲故事的人当然就是骗子；所以也许，在那荣耀的背后，是一个关于人性的顽皮真相。冰岛和挪威的传奇故事创造者们是我们所熟悉的，但我很久以前读过——我不记得是谁写的了，所以我可能记得很离谱。但我读到的是，好比说在战斗结束时的山坡上会有两堆篝火，一堆篝火周围围着一群人，在听传奇故事创造者讲述，
who would tell how Hengist had destroyed 40 people with, you know, his sword and killed another 20 just by strangling them, and how heroic he was. Then around the other bonfire would be the glee man who would tell how Hergis did actually not manage to strap his sword and had fallen over, but he had fallen over on top of two of the enemy and squashed them. And he would tell a satirical comic version of the battle. And in a strange sort of way, the Trojan War is like that. There is this noble roster of extraordinary heroes and their incredible courage and their skill with swords and spears and bows and arrows and chariots and all the rest of it.
他会讲述亨吉斯特（Hengist）如何仅凭一把剑就消灭了40个人，又仅仅通过勒死的方式杀死了另外20个人，以及他是多么的英雄。然后另一堆篝火周围则是一个滑稽艺人，他会讲述赫吉斯特实际上根本没能拔出剑，而是摔倒了，但他摔倒在了两个敌人身上并把他们压扁了。他会讲述一个关于这场战斗的讽刺性的喜剧版本。从某种奇特的角度来看，特洛伊战争就是这样的。这里有高贵卓越的英雄名册，有他们不可思议的勇气，以及他们使用剑、长矛、弓箭、战车和所有这一切的技巧。
But then there is this deceitful wicked um figure this delightful cunning Odysseus who strokes his chin and thinks up ways of using deceit to win the war and that is what wins it followed by appalling violence of course but but that's it's as if because I think one of the things about Greek myth is that Greeks must have and I I know it's wrong to say must have, they must have noticed that they now had the writing that the Phoenicians had given them, the Cadmian alphabet, as they called it. So that was fine. But they'd built up a civilisation
但接着又有这样一个诡异邪恶的人物——那个令人喜爱的、狡猾的奥德修斯，他抚摸着下巴，想出各种利用诡计来赢得战争的方法，而这正是赢得战争的关键，当然随之而来的是骇人听闻的暴力。但但这就好比——因为我认为希腊神话的一个特点是，希腊人一定曾经……我知道说“一定”是不对的，但他们一定注意到他们现在拥有了腓尼基人给他们的文字，也就是他们所说的卡德摩斯字母。所以这很好。但他们建立了一个文明，
that was actually better than the one across the sea, the Egyptian one that existed for thousands of years and barely changed in that time. It takes an egyptologist to say oh that particular pylon is 3 000 years old that one is 5 000 years old but that's 2 000 year difference you know i mean if you go back 2 000 years from from now you're in the year 10 20 or 40 years before before the battle of hastings and it's a very different world. Whereas the Egyptians stayed the same, and the Greeks appeared to be the first civilisation
这个文明实际上比海那边的那个文明——存在了数千年且在这期间几乎没有改变的埃及文明——还要好。必须得是埃及古物学者才会说：“哦，那个特定的塔门有三千年历史了，那个有五千年历史。”但这中间有两千年的差距，你知道的，我的意思是，如果你从现在往回数两千年，你是在公元10年，或者在黑斯廷斯战役前40年，那是一个非常不同的世界。而埃及人保持不变，希腊人似乎是第一个文明，
that believed in progress, that wanted to learn new things and change and add and adapt and adopt and evolve in terms of their civilisation, their policy, their polities, their city-states, the way they were run. And of course one can romanticize and idealize the Greeks far too much. We know that they also had slaves and they were brutal to their own people when they needed to be and so on, or felt they needed to be. But they were unusual and they looked at humanity, it seems seems in a different way to previous civilizations
他们信仰进步，渴望学习新事物、改变、增加、适应、采纳并在文明、政治、政体、城邦以及管理方式上不断进化。当然，人们可以把希腊人浪漫化、理想化得过头。我们知道他们也有奴隶，在需要的时候对本国人民也很残忍，诸如此类，或者说他们觉得自己有必要这么做。但他们是不寻常的，他们看待人性的方式，似乎与之前的文明不同。
of course we can only go from either an archaeological record and look at objects or from a historical record when writing arrives again uh after the collapse of the bronze age and the you know arrival of the phoen alphabet, you can start to see that the Greeks were interested in what humans were. And they wrote plays and philosophy evolved that examined human motive and in ways that we don't have any evidence that other people did. And they may have done, of course, but they didn't leave it on cuneiform tablets and they didn't leave it in any other record for us to see clearly that they had anything like the greeks fascination with the ambiguity complexity contrariness of human motive and behavior and that
当然，我们只能根据考古记录来观察器物，或者根据青铜时代崩溃后文字再次出现、腓尼基字母传入后的历史记录来了解。你可以开始看到，希腊人对人类是什么很感兴趣。他们写戏剧，演化出哲学，以我们没有证据证明其他人曾经有过的方式去审视人类的动机。当然，他们可能也这么做过，但他们没有把这些留在楔形文字泥板上，也没有留下任何其他记录，好让我们清楚地看到他们有任何类似希腊人那样对人类动机和行为的模糊性、复杂性、矛盾性的着迷，并且
people weren't just as i say the early version they weren't just four-bit blocky non-resolved but that people were complicated and they had warring gods inside them and athens itself and greece and you know was a confusing thing and there were different ways you could choose to live. And you could live by your wits or you could live by martial prowess. And the Greeks never resolved it. The Romans decided martial prowess would be it. And they re-aligned Greek mythology in ways to emphasize that. I mean, you know far more about this than me, Tom. I'd love to hear you talk about the religion of Rome,
人们不只是像我说的早期版本那样——不只是四比特分块的、未解析的非黑即白，而是人们很复杂，他们内心有着交战的神明，雅典本身、希腊以及你知道的，是一个令人困惑的事物，并且有不同的生活方式可供选择。你可以靠你的机智生活，也可以靠你的武艺生活。而希腊人从未解决这个矛盾。罗马人决定以武艺为主。他们重新调整了希腊神话，以强调这一点。我的意思是，你对这方面的了解比我多得多，汤姆。我很想听你谈谈罗马的宗教，
which is much easier to talk about than the religion of Greece, although there was a religious caste in the time of Athens. Of course, they put Socrates to death. But in Rome, the way they changed Ares to Mars, for example, or the way they changed Aphrodite to Venus, the gods became symbols of a Roman attitude, didn't they more? Well, I think the Roman gods are more analog. Yes, yes. To pursue your metaphor. And I think that you're talking about Odysseus
谈论罗马宗教比谈论希腊宗教容易得多，尽管在雅典时代也有一个宗教阶层。当然，他们处死了苏格拉底。但在罗马，他们把阿瑞斯变成玛尔斯的方式，或者把阿芙罗狄蒂变成维纳斯的方式，这些神明变得更像是罗马态度的象征了，不是吗？嗯，我认为罗马诸神更具类比性。是的，是的。顺着你的隐喻说下去。而且我认为你谈到奥德修斯时，
as being kind of cunning and clever and smart and mobile and contradictory. And then you moved on to talking about Athens in very similar terms. And of course, the god who joins them both is Athena, who, for my money, is the greatest deity of all time because she's so complicated. You know, she is the god of the battle line, but she's also the god of the loom and of the arts of civilization. And I think it speaks wonderfully of Odysseus that Athena chooses him to be her favourite. And I think it speaks wonderfully of the Athenians, that she chooses
说他狡猾、聪明、灵活且充满矛盾。接着你以非常相似的方式谈到了雅典。当然，将两者结合在一起的神明是雅典娜。依我之见，她是史上最伟大的神祇，因为她如此复杂。你知道，她是战线之神，但她也是织布机和文明艺术之神。我认为雅典娜选择奥德修斯作为她最喜爱的人，这极好地说明了奥德修斯的特质；而她选择雅典人作为她的子民、她所关照的人，这也极好地说明了雅典人的特质。我记得当我还是个孩子的时候，意识到这一点就像是完成了从神话通往历史的“入门毒品”式的跨越，让我觉得雅典人就像古代世界的奥德修斯。当然，关于雅典有一个神话般的起源故事，暗示其实是雅典人选择了雅典娜，而不是她选择了他们——雅典娜和波塞冬曾来到这座城市的人民面前，问他们希望哪个神成为他们的守护神。
them to be her people, the people that she looks out for. And I remember as a child that realising that was what served as the gateway drug of moving from mythology to history, of thinking that the Athenians were the kind of Odysseus of the ancient world. Of course, there is one mythic sort of origin story of Athens that suggests that actually the Athenians chose Athena rather than she choosing them, that Athena and Poseidon went to the people of the city and asked them which god they wanted to be their patron.
波塞冬给他们提供了泉水以及诸如此类的东西、好的潮汐之类的，并说他不会引发任何地震。而雅典娜在这个特定版本中，给他们提供了橄榄树。我会选橄榄树。是的，他们决定选择橄榄树，他们可以用橄榄木建造船只。他们可以把橄榄油用在各种地方，
And Poseidon offered them spring water and all that, and good tides and things like that, and said he wouldn't send any earthquakes. And Athena, in this particular version, offered them the olive. I'd go for the olive. Yeah, and they decided with the olive, they could build ships out of olive wood. They could use the oil in all kinds of ways
还可以吃橄榄果。所以他们认为这比波塞冬所能承诺的任何东西都更有价值。让我问你一个非常平凡的问题。关于你采用的语调。所以你说你收到了很多来自孩子们的信件。我想知道……当您刚开始创作时，您是怎么想的？您是从神话和英雄故事开始的，您当时把这些……您并没有把它们当作儿童读物对吧？不，我没有。但我确实记得，我是在童年时爱上它们的，并且
and the fruit of the olive to eat. And so they decided that that was a more valuable thing than anything Poseidon could promise them. Let me ask you a very humdrum question. It's about the tone of voice that you adopt. So you're saying that you get a lot of correspondence from children. And I'm wondering whether that um when you started did you think of the so you started with the mythos and the heroes did you think of these you didn't think of them as children's books right no I didn't but I did remember that it was as a child that I fell in love with them and that
我读过罗伯特·格雷夫斯的书，他写了两个版本的合集，一个是给成年人看的，还有一个也是儿童版。我很快就转向了成人版，因为我喜欢脚注的细节以及他讲述的那些非凡的小插曲。所以我基本上是为聪明的年轻人、刚进入青春期的群体而写的。我心里想的是——因为当我最初考虑这件事时，这让我感到非常重要——那就是炉边感，那种围坐在火堆旁的感觉。你知道，就像很多人一样，我读过尤瓦尔·赫拉利的书，一直在思考早期人类以及早期工具的发展、
I read Robert Graves who who wrote two versions of his collection, one for adults and a children's version as well. And I soon went to the adult one because I loved the detail of footnotes and all these extraordinary little side stories he told. So I was sort of writing for an intelligent young adult, early teen kind of to as much as anything. And what I had in mind, because it struck me as so important when I was first thinking about this was the, the sense of the hearth, the, the, the sitting around a fire that, you know, like a lot of people I'd read Noah, who Val Harari and, and had been thinking about early mankind and the development
然后是火的发展等等，以及五万年前语言的诞生。我在想，好吧，五万年前，语言和火让人类在傍晚时分拥有了更多的安全感，也有了更多的闲暇时间，卡路里来得更容易了，而且你知道的，动物也开始被慢慢驯化来干活等等。所以在一天结束时，孩子们围坐在火堆旁，当他们听到风在树林里沙沙作响时，会问：那风是什么？那是什么声音？是谁在驱动它？它从哪里来？因为人类每当看到某种代理力量、某种力、某种运动、某种动机——从词源上讲，动机不就是运动吗？——一旦有了运动，你就得问自己是什么引起了这种运动，而这正是牛顿所探究的本质：
of early tools and then of fire and so on and of language 50,000 years ago. And I was thinking, well, okay, 50,000 years ago, language and fire have allowed human beings a great deal more safety of an evening and a great deal more leisure time the calories come cheaper now and uh you know animals are slowly being uh harnessed to to work and so on and so children are sitting around the fire at the end of the day and saying as they hear the wind rustling in the trees what is that wind what is that noise who drives it where does it come from because human beings whenever there's an agency a force a movement a motive which is the same as a movement etymologically isn't it a motion where as soon as there is motion you have to ask yourself what causes it and that is the essence of what newton
是什么引起了这种运动？我无法探究其根本，我能在某种程度上理解风，虽然了解得不多，但人们有一种感觉，风有物理上的解释，它不是神。但所有其他会动的东西——甚至是什么推动果实从枝头长出、抽出花蕾和绿叶，然后又是什么导致它们掉落？孩子们会问这个问题，而大人们则回答：“哦，好吧，如果你不知道答案，那就赋予它一个代理力量，这就是我们所说的神。”你会说，存在着这样一种力量把果实推了出来。然后围绕着母亲——大麦女神得墨忒耳，这位掌管食物和果实等的伟大女神——就会产生一个故事，
asked what causes this motion i can't get behind it i can understand wind to some extent not hugely but there was a sense that wind had a physical explanation wasn't a god but everything else that moves even what is it that pushes fruit out of twigs and blossom and leaves, and then what causes them to drop? And the children ask this, and the adults say, oh, well, if you don't know the answer, then you give it an agency, and that's what we call a god. You say there is this force that pushes the fruit out. And then a story develops around the mother, the barley mother, Demeter, the great goddess of food and fruit and so on,
讲述她是如何完成这一切的。然后，她为什么又停下来了？为什么……为什么它在秋天停下来？啊，好吧，然后就是那个故事……所以你会得到一种类似于吉卜林的《如此故事》（Just So Stories）的故事——我想它们的专业术语叫病因学故事（etiological stories）。这些都是你可以讲述的故事，用来把你的家庭、群体、氏族、
and how she does all this. And then why does she stop? Why doesn't it, why does it stop in the autumn? Ah, well, and then the story of, you know, so you get a kind of kipling just so story etiological stories is the technical name for them i think and um these are all stories you can just tell to to bind you as a family a group a clan a clan, a tribe, a community generally, abound by these stories they tell. And then as they trade with groups over in another valley
部落、通常是一个社区紧密联系在一起，被这些他们讲述的故事所凝聚。然后，当他们与另一个山谷甚至海湾对岸的群体进行贸易时，那些群体对他们的神会有一个略有不同的故事。所以你把它们混合起来，就会得到一种所谓的“融合式”的不同宗教的混合，以及不同的宗教，你甚至记不清那个神是哪来的了。但所有这一切都发生在你有语言但还没有文字的时候。然后发生的事情是，大约在同一时期，两个伟大的希腊人——赫西奥德（Hesiod，顺便说一句，别问我关于元音和希腊语发音的问题，
or even across a bay, and those groups will have a slightly different story about their god. So you mix them and you get a syncretic, as they call it, sort of mixture of different religions happening and different, you can't quite remember where that one came from. But all this is while you have language, but you haven't yet got writing. But then what happened is that roughly the same time, two great Greeks, Hesiod stroke Hesiod, I never, don't ask me about vowels and Greek pronunciation.
美国人和英国人读音不同。你可以说Hesiod，也可以说Hesiod）。总之，他和荷马在差不多同一时期，开始为这些故事赋予了一种形态，并从那时起一直延续至今。所以从这个意义上说，它们变得文学化了。赫西奥德写下了《神谱》（Theogony），讲述了诸神的诞生，并给出了非常清晰的故事，说明谁是父亲、谁是母亲，他们都来自哪里。人们猜测他是在口耳相传的故事的基础上进行创作的，但他是有意识地将它们写下来并赋予其形态。
Americans and Britain say different things. You may say Hesiod, you may say Hesiod. Anyway, he and Homer, around the same time, started to give a shape that has stayed with these stories ever since. And so they've become, in that sense, literary. Hesiod wrote down the birth of the gods, theogony, and gave very clear stories of who was the father and the mother and where they all came from. And one assumes he was working on what had been stories told orally, but he was self-consciously writing them down and giving them a shape.
他做事的方式具有一种权威性，这意味着后代会说：“好吧，去查查你的赫西奥德。”所以到了柏拉图那一代人，他们都在引用他，引用荷马，是荷马赋予了这些故事真实的形态，所以我想，这里有了一个官方版本，就像后来亚瑟王传奇也有了官方版本一样。会有这些不同的版本……然后马洛里等人把它们整理成……接着你会说，不，这是这个版本，也就是湖中仙子和宝剑拔出来的那个版本。
And there was an authority to the way he he did it which meant subsequent generations would say well look up in your hessian so by the time you get to plato and those sort of people they're referring to him and they're referring to homer who's given these stories an authentic shape so they've there's an official version i suppose in the same way there became an official version. I suppose, in the same way, there became an official version for the Arthur legends. There have been these different... Then Mallory and others put them into... And then you say, well, no, this is the version, the Lady in the Lake version with the sword coming out.
或者说到罗宾汉，你会说，这里的版本是这样的。它们成了官方版本。但总有这样一种感觉，那就是它们最初……说到罗宾汉，你会说，这里的版本是这样的，你知道的。它们成了官方版本。但总有这样一种感觉，那就是它们最初只是家人们给孩子们讲的故事，为了逗孩子们开心，同时也为了解释豹子怎么会有斑纹，可以说是这样。是的。所以，斯蒂芬，当你想到这一点——这种历经千百年的传承链条，
Or with Robin Hood, you say, this is the version here. And they become official. But there's always that sense that they started with Robin Hood, you say, this is the version here, you know. And they become official. But there's always that sense that they started with just families telling stories to keep their children amused and to tell them how the leopard got its spots, as it were. Yes. So, Stephen, when you think about that, this kind of chain of transmission going thousands and thousands of years,
然后想到这条链条上的所有环节：从荷马、维吉尔，穿过中世纪、文艺复兴，一直到现代——我的意思是，你有这种意识吗？你有影响的焦虑，还是根本不去想这种影响的厚重感？这很有趣，汤姆，它在两个方向上同时发生。一方面，我感到彻底的自由，因为我认为这些是民间故事。从荣格的意义上讲，它们是远古以来整个人类集体无意识的一部分。它们上面没有任何版权标记。如果有什么东西是公共领域的，那就是它们了。但另一方面，是的，
and then you think about all the links in that chain from Homer, Virgil, through the Middle Ages, through the Renaissance, into the modern age. I mean do you have a consciousness of that? Do you have the anxiety of influence or do you not think of that weight of influence at all? It's funny Tom, it happens in both directions. On the one hand, I feel completely free because I think these are folk stories. They are in the Jungian sense, part of the collective unconsciousness of a whole people from long ago. They don't have any copyright marks on them. Their public domain, if ever ever anything was but on the other hand yes
这些故事经过了我之前每一位伟大的诗人和作家的打磨、镀金和完善，从这个意义上说，我是极其不配的。但你能得到的最大安慰就是：我不会毁了它们，至少我希望不会。我的意思是，那将是……那将太糟糕了。因为当你回溯过去，看看那些大人物——特别是两位特别重要的美国人，他们曾在一个多世纪里统治着美国人的童年，那就是托马斯·布尔芬奇（Thomas Bulfinch）和纳撒尼尔·霍桑（Nathaniel Hawthorne）。纳撒尼尔·霍桑为孩子们写了《坦格夷代尔故事集》（Tanglewood Tales），在书中他讲述了一些希腊神话中的伟大故事——
these are stories that have been burnished and gilded and perfected by every every great poet and and writer before me and and i am in that sense utterly unworthy but the best you can feel is that i can't spoil them i can't at least i hope not i mean that would be that would just be awful i mean the because you go back you look at um some of the big names a couple of big americans in particular who had dominated uh american childhoods for over a hundred years would be thomas bullfinch and nathaniel hawthorne who who both Nathaniel Hawthorne wrote his Tanglewood Tales for children in which he told some of the um the great stories of Greek myth um particularly the sort of Ovid stories of transformations um and and Bullfinch told his
特别是奥维德式的变形故事；而布尔芬奇则讲述了那些被大量美化、但极其精彩刺激的希腊神话故事，它们伴随着孩子们成长。当然，他们使用的语言比如“swain”（青年农夫/情郎），你知道的，某人是个swain——嗯，我们现在已经没有swain了，我们不知道swain是什么。但我当时在想，好吧，我确信我的语言会过时，因为这是必然的。你无法阻止它过时。但我不会——我尽量不通过做一些你在这些现代希腊神话儿童绘本中偶尔看到的事情来加速它的过时，在那些书里，你知道的，法厄同（Phaeton）成了一个住在弗里吉亚之类地方的“潮人”（dude）。你会想，嗯，我才不会管他们叫潮人呢，我不会……你知道的，这不符合我的风格。你会想，嗯，我才不会管他们叫潮人呢，我不会，你知道的，这不符合我的风格。这有失你的水准，斯蒂芬。
very burglarized but but excellently exciting stories of greek myth and they stayed for children and of course they use language like you know swain you know someone's a swain well that's we don't have swains anymore we don't know what a swain is but i was so i i was thinking well i'm sure my language will date because it will. You can't stop it from dating. But I won't, I try not to accelerate its dating by doing what you occasionally see in these illustrated versions of modern Greek myth for children in which, you know, Phaeton was this dude who lived in, you know, Phrygia or something. And you think, well, I'm not going to call them dudes. I'm not, you know, they just, it's not me. And you think, well, I'm not going to call them dudes. I'm not, you know, they're just, it's not me. And that's beneath you, Stephen.
好吧，我的意思是，我能理解为什么人们会希望让这些角色显得更加生动活泼。他们可能会认为使用南区街头俚语是个好方法。但这只是我个人做不来的方式。我认为还有一点是，有很大一部分孩子并不符合我们对传统儿童的想象。换句话说，他们并没有把一生都埋在
Well, I mean, I can understand why people would want, you know, to make these characters appear more vivid and alive. And they might think that using, you know, South Side Street slang is a good way of doing it. It's just not the way I could do it personally. I think another thing is there is a huge proportion of children who are not what we think children are. In other words, who don't spend their lives with their heads buried
Instagram、Snapchat、TikTok等各种软件里，他们其实觉得那些东西有点无聊，反而喜欢在图书馆里发现古旧东西的感觉。我敢肯定，如果我现在十五岁，我也会是那样。我会想远离网络。我会和朋友们开玩笑说：“咱们用真正的固定电话吧。好的，我们下周见。”你知道的，确实如此。所有这些……我会选择“隐居”，因为那很有趣。甚至用油印机去制作一本杂志，
in Instagram and Snapchat and TikTok and so on, who actually think it's a bit lame and who love the idea of discovering old musty things in libraries. I'm sure that if I were 15 now, I would be like that. I would want to go off grid. I would have fun with my friends saying, let's use real telephones. Okay, let's meet next week. You know, exactly. And all that sort week. You know, exactly. And all that, I'd sort of, you know, go off the grid because it would be fun. Or even produce a magazine using a Gestetner duplicator
而不是去扫描各种东西。仅仅因为这在它自己的方式中……当然有点自命不凡，但你会成为那种喜欢回顾过去的“帮派”的一员。我当学生时，穿着硬领衬衫，在做所有这些复古的事情时，简直是个十足的讨厌鬼。但斯蒂芬，你那么热爱科技。
rather than, you know, just scanning things. Just because it would be a, you know, in its own way, pretentious, of course, but one would be part of that gang that liked looking back. And I was, when I was a schoolboy, I wore stiff collars and was a complete prick as far as, you know, doing all these, you know, looking old-fashioned. But Stephen, you love your technology.
我知道，这才是怪事。你以热爱科技而闻名。是的。我知道我们霸占了你太长时间，但我只是想说……从某种意义上说，谈论这些非常古老的传说，以及人们如何聚集并讨论它们，是多么令人感动。而此时此刻，你在加利福尼亚，我们在英格兰，我们却依然在讨论这些故事。我要感谢你
I know, that's the weird thing. Famous for loving your technology. Yeah. I'm aware that we've kept you for far too long, but I just wanted to say how i mean in a way how moving it is to be talking that you were talking about these very ancient tales and about how people gather and discuss them and here we are you're in california we're in england and yet still we're talking about these stories and and to thank you for
能来这里和我们谈论这些。这简直是古代与现代的一种奇妙融合。这真是我的荣幸，汤姆。我必须说——尽管我刚才还没来得及说——我是你们两位作品的超级崇拜者。我非常喜欢你们所做的事。实际上，多米尼克，我听过你的有声书，《烈日下的季节》（Seasons in the Sun）和《白色炽热》（White Heat）。它们真的非常棒。
for having come on and and talk to us about it it. It's kind of an amazing synergy of ancient and modern. It's such a pleasure, Tom. And I have to say, which I haven't managed to do, what an admirer I am of both your work. I love what you do. And I've listened to them as audiobooks, actually, Dominic, Seasons in the Sun and White Heat. They actually work really well.
当然，我正好处于那个年龄段，伴随着你们如此精彩地呈现在我们面前的60年代和70年代成长起来。所以你们两个完美地为西方历史作了前后呼应的注脚。斯蒂芬，我们应该给你付钱才对。你为这期播客提供了完美的收尾。斯蒂芬，非常感谢你能来，并祝你的新书一切顺利。
And, of course, I'm exactly the age when I was growing up through these periods of the 60s and 70s in particular that you bring to life so brilliantly. And so between you, you bookend Western history rather fabulously. Stephen, we should be paying you for this. You provide us with the perfect end for this podcast. Stephen, we can't thank you enough for having come on and wishing you all the very best with the book.
非常感谢。真的很荣幸。谢谢你们。好，刚才那是斯蒂芬·弗赖。汤姆，在谈话过程中我能看到你的表情。你听得很开心，对吧？这完全符合你的胃口。确实如此。
Thanks so much. A real pleasure. Thank you. So that was Stephen Fry. Tom, I could see your face during that conversation. You were loving that, weren't you? That was right up your alley. It really was.
尤其是因为，正如我在采访中所说的那样，我正在创作《特洛伊战争》的续集，在那个故事里，神明是真实存在的。所以听到斯蒂芬对此的看法，以及它如何与希腊历史相关联，并更广泛地与我们理解过去的方式——
And particularly because, as I said, in the course of the interview, I'm doing this kind of sequel to the Trojan War, where the gods are real. So hearing Stephen's views on that and how it relates to Greek history and more generally to the kind of, the way that we understand the past,
尤其是希腊的过去——相关联，我认为这太棒了，真的非常有趣。让我问你一个简单的问题，顺着和斯蒂芬的聊天继续延伸。他的书销量极其惊人。你认为历史上有那么一天——我是说在可预见的未来——人们会对这些东西失去兴趣，当它们只剩下晦涩的古董研究，而这些神话不再发挥这种作用？我的意思是，与维多利亚时期相比，它们现在发挥的作用已经变小了，不是吗？我当时觉得，这个问题几乎一直悬在我们讨论的所有内容之上，因为我们拥有
Greek past particularly, I thought it was fantastic, really interesting. Let me ask you a quick question, just coming off the back of a chat with Stephen. So his books have been colossal sellers. Do you think there'll ever be a point in history, I mean, in the foreseeable future when people will lose interest in this stuff, when it will just become sort of obscure antiquarianism and these myths will no longer play such a role i mean already they play a smaller role than they did in say the victorian period don't they i thought that that question was hanging over the whole everything we talked about pretty much because it we had the
这样一个社会和教育体系的背景：它完全是为了研究这些神话而建立的，而现在我们不再这样做了。然而，斯蒂芬的书的成功表明，你并不需要人们对古典学有极其深厚的根基，
context of a society and education system that was completely geared to studying these myths and now we no longer do and yet the success of steven's books shows that you don't need people to be completely grounded in the classics yeah for children to get obsessed by it because the stories are so strong they're so strong that people respond to them instinctively and you know just looking at the way that it's been reinterpreted and reinterpreted and reinterpreted that doesn't happen because there's you you know, there are school teachers or cultural conservatives saying, you've got to enjoy this. It happens because there is something about them that instinctively encourages people to retell them, reinterpret them, and draw kind of an understanding of the world from it that I think, I think, you know, it will endure forever.
也能让孩子们对它们着迷，因为这些故事太有力量了。它们太强大了，以至于人们会对它们产生本能的共鸣。你知道，只要看看这些故事被不断地重新诠释、重新诠释、再重新诠释，就会发现，这种情况发生并不是因为有什么学校老师或文化保守主义者在说“你们必须喜欢这个”。它的发生是因为它们本身有一种特质，本能地鼓励人们去重新讲述它们、重新诠释它们，并从中汲取对世界的理解。我认为，我认为，你知道的，这种力量将永远延续下去。
Actually, one of my favourite reinterpretations of the trojan war is um a science fiction novel by a guy called dan simmons i don't know if you've come across it you read a book called ilium uh and it's set in the shadow of mount olympus mount olympus of course is the largest mountain on mars and um nano enhanced superhumans are restaging the trojan war and they are kind of in the role of the gods intervening. And in a way, it's kind of the best fictional recreation of the power of the gods relative to humans that I've come across. And I think that, you know, I can absolutely imagine in 3000 AD that people will still be reading the Trojan War
其实，我最喜欢的对特洛伊战争的重新诠释之一，是一个名叫丹·西蒙斯（Dan Simmons）的家伙写的一本科幻小说，不知道你有没有看过。你读过一本书叫《伊利昂》（Ilium）吗？它的背景设定在奥林匹斯山的阴影下——奥林匹斯山当然是火星上最大的山，
and maybe doing it on Mars, who knows? Great. Well, that's a good note on which to end. So that's our chat with Stephen Fry and we'll be returning to more normal service next time. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
纳米增强的超级人类正在那里重演特洛伊战争，他们扮演着干预其中的诸神角色。从某种意义上说，这是我见过的对诸神相对于人类力量的最佳虚构重塑。我想，我完全可以想象在公元3000年，人们仍会在阅读特洛伊战争，也许还会顺便在火星上读它，谁知道呢？太棒了。好吧，这是一个很好的结束语。以上就是我们与斯蒂芬·弗赖的访谈，下次我们将恢复正常节目。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。